no when i left when i left ohio
i left some of my biases behind
with pro sports teams because i figured
i'd be covering
pro sports teams around the country i
can't just be i can't be repping
the cavaliers and and the cleveland
indians and these other places but i
can't take ohio state football with me
ohio state football
has always been a part of my life i love
the buckeyes i still believe to this day
that they lost the game to michigan in
2003
because i couldn't watch that game i
begged my editor at the boston globe
dawn square i said please don't have me
covering harvard yale
because ohio state and michigan are
playing and i got to watch this game
ohio state got blown out in that game
and then i don't think they've lost a
mission since
okay maybe maybe once or twice
so i understand the importance of big
ten football and it means a lot to me
but one thing i don't love more than big
ten football
is safety uh one thing i don't love more
than uh
uh big ten football is life
so look coming from the midwest
the one thing i love about the area is
that people just tell you
like it is they just it's just straight
up it's not like a lot of uh it's not a
lot of nuance in the midwest just like
hey you like it or you don't
straight up i'm gonna tell you so can i
just say this
on one hand it's good that that that big
ten football
supposedly will be played scheduled to
be played in october
that's good october 24th is supposed to
be the first game
and that is a reversal from what the
leaked from what the the conference's
commissioner
and chancellors and presidents put out
in august
can we be straight this ain't about new
information
so if you can say oh no if you can say
it's not about new information if you
can just admit
it's not about student athletes it's not
doing what's best for these kids
this is about money cue the oj some
people
got to have it it's what it is it's 66
million dollars at the base
and more money coming when you are part
of the power five conferences so don't
tell me this is about safety
this don't tell me that it's about
college presidents and chancellors
sitting down at the table and rethinking
that it's all about money
and if you admit that okay more power to
you but don't tell me
that the science has changed because the
science has not changed
and there's a very good chance michael
smith that by october 24th
there could be an outbreak there could
be
those numbers going up and what are you
going to do then
are you going to do the right thing are
you going to are you going to follow the
money
there's outbreaks now yes our college
campuses are hot spots all over the
country i believe michigan state
you know has an outbreak that they're
dealing with now i mean
wisconsin's dealing with with covert 19
maryland i mean this is it was the right
decision
then and it would have been the right
decision
now to sit this one out you know how
your mama
you know she's saying if everybody jump
over bridge you go jump too like that's
what this is this is peer pressure
this is peer and political pressure this
is well
the nfl's playing well excuse me they're
professional athletes you know
um they're getting paid to do it you
know
uh they're not like none of these people
are gonna be in a bubble in college
football or isolated from their the rest
of their campuses which again
it outbreaks left and right around the
country um
this is well the you know the sec is
about to play
we just we just watched college football
kick off this week the acc's playing
why can't we play i mean the fact that
larry scott from the pac-12
had to put out a statement today saying
we're not ready to play well duh
the west coast is literally on fire
right now
meanwhile you have usc students writing
the governor
of california gavin newsom saying please
help us
we want to play when he's literally
trying to put out
fires elsewhere and they're asking to
play
so what boggles the mind here is how
exploited
college athletes in particular college
football players have been
for decades and decades and now their
fault and i get the opportunity i get
they have dreams of playing in the nfl i
understand this once in a lifetime i get
all that
type of stuff but we're talking about
life and death here like you just laid
out
and they're begging literally begging to
put their bodies and lives
on the line for free for the most part
and it's like wait guys can we step back
here and then i mention the political
pressure here i believe within the last
hour or so
i believe your boy in the white house
had a conference call maybe or maybe the
or maybe just the white house
and not the president himself had a
conference call
regarding trump's involvement in
bringing back big ten football i've been
saying this
privately you know you could attest to
it that that
everything he was doing with getting
kevin warren on the phone the commission
of the big ten
everything he was doing was is all
always be closing always be selling
everything about it
it fascinates me donald trump wants to
be president but doesn't want the job
he wants the title he wants a position
he wants the spotlight he ain't trying
to do the work
my man said that he read bob woodward's
book in one night
first of all it shocks me that he can
actually read i'm convinced he can't
comprehend
and there's no way that he was reading a
book that long and that and that
comprehensive
in one night i digress everything for
him about the big ten
was his way of campaigning in these
battleground states like michigan
and wisconsin to try to take credit for
bringing back big ten football so my
hope and prayer
beyond the health and safety which i
don't trust the process
i don't trust the people involved and to
your point michael i don't trust the
motivations or the agendas behind it
i don't trust the information i don't
trust the idea of medical advancements
yes you're doing rapid daily testing but
we don't know anything about this
disease but my hope and prayer
is that in the grand scheme beyond the
health and safety of these players in
the short term and maybe even long term
when it comes to the health issues
associated with covid
my prayer is that the people who may be
on the fence about voting
who haven't voted yet hopefully you
voted by now but who may be on the fence
about voting
are not swayed by the idea that somehow
donald trump helped break big ten
football
back to the midwest which as you pointed
out off the top is a way of life to
these people
it is a way of life and i wonder i
wonder you know what that experience is
going to be like
you know watching big ten football cause
we all like it for example man i still
have family all over the state of ohio
so columbus to see columbus on a
saturday afternoon
i mean the time everybody knows ohio
state football is playing
if you got some stuff to do if you're
not into ohio state football that's a
rare person by the way he's not into it
but if you're not into it
that's your time to go grocery shopping
that's your time to go to the mall or
whatever
because the streets are empty it's all
about
tailgating and the game and everything
all the bars and restaurants
around the game around ohio stadium so
that's gonna be a different experience
it's not like
it's it's it's not gonna be the saturday
tradition but that's beside the point
here it is you mentioned the political
part of it there's a political part of
it uh
nationally and there's a political part
of it within academia
now i can say this because i mess around
with academia every now and then
a lot of it when i did say i stopped
cussing so i can't i can't really say
what i really want to say but a lot of
it is just so
bogus it's bs you can
you can tell what somebody is really
about when money is not factored in when
they don't need your money
when they don't need your money and
they're not thirsting for money
then you can see what the real decision
is
and the big ten is all about
power five money so let's go to the
opposite the opposite of the big ten
it's the ivy league right i mean ivy
league okay we're not
we're not in it to the power five we're
not even in the sports
so harvard has the biggest endowment in
the world
they don't need your money they're not
thirsting for your money harvard was one
of the first schools to say
oh no it's not safe we're not coming
back to campus
and we're not playing sports done
because it's not about money for them
it's really about the most intelligent
decision and michael i i know this i
know this to be true
i hope i'm wrong but i know i'm not on
this within the big ten
michigan hate to say something nice
about michigan michigan
has one of the top science programs in
the big ten if not the top science
program
in that conference you mean to tell me
there's not a professor
or professors at michigan who can
contradict all of the tripe that we have
heard today
about new information and protocols
i know there's somebody who's who's a
specialist
on infectious diseases who can say wait
a minute this is a little too risky
we shouldn't be doing this we're doing
this
because of pressure and money and
christina johnson
the president of ohio state let me tell
you
know where the power is you're not the
president of ohio state ryan day is
ryan davis president and and and this is
that ring
crow kiss that ryan day jim harbaugh
with help from his brother john
they have been in nebraska i mean it was
talk early on about you know everyone
play our own season
they have never been right with this
decision in the big ten
i i'm not saying kevin warren has done
everything right i know he's come under
a lot of fire
but that was an 11-3 vote the first time
unanimous this time
they had to kyle tower and cater so much
internal
and external pressure peer and political
pressure i want to read you something
this is from nicole arbach she shared
this this is part of the statement about
the protocols listen to this
all covet 19 positive student athletes
will have to undergo comprehensive
cardiac testing
to include labs and boy markers
ecg echo cardiogram and cardiac mri
following cardiac evaluation
student athletes must receive clearance
from a cardiologist
designated by the university for the
primary purpose of cardiac clearance for
colby 19 positive student athletes
the earliest student athlete can return
to game competition is 21 days following
a kobe 19
positive diagnosis this way it gets fun
and i mean that tongue-in-cheek
in addition to the medical protocols
approved the 14 big 10 institutions
will establish a cardiac registry in an
effort to examine
the effects on covit 19 positive student
athletes
the registry and associated data will
attempt to answer many of the
unknowns regarding the cardiac
manifestations
and covert 19 positive elite athletes
you don't take the field with unknowns
as it relates to the human heart
you just don't do it and it's just
listen
it's eight eight games in eight weeks
and i know people around the country
are just clamoring to get back to some
sense
of course but we're about to go into
into a stretch intuition intuition the
toughness stretch maybe that's saying
something almost 200 000 people dead
we're about to go into flu season you
know there are outbreaks happening all
over college campuses
and where everybody's just trying to act
like this virus somehow
cares about our inconveniences and it
doesn't
it doesn't now there's news today about
a plan to make a free vaccine available
all of its politics
all of this all of us employ for votes i
don't know about you michael
i'm gonna be among the last people
vaccinated i already feel like i'm one
of the last people quarantining now i'm
gonna already feel like one of the last
people social distancing now
i will be the last person getting this
vaccine i'm not gonna be a guinea pig
and it's unfortunate that these young
people
are going to be people's guinea pigs in
the name of money as you pointed out
yeah it's in the name of money and and
let's not look if it's about money go
ahead and say it because i i can
i can understand it i can understand if
that's your motivation
let's just be clear about it just take
away
all of the extras let's take away all of
of the red herrings about
how these student athletes and you know
you know doing what's best and
and trying to develop these young men
look
this is where this is where covet 19 was
convenient
uh in terms of power five football
conferences it happened in march
so you can look good in march hey we're
doing the right thing
now we're doing the right thing it is
just best it is best to shut it down
because you don't have college football
in march someone's not really affecting
you
but now when people are thinking in
march oh yeah
we're not gonna it's not gonna be here
in the fall now that it's affecting the
fall
everybody is really declaring what this
is all about